pets are in many ways just like people
just like people can eat lots of
different kinds of diets and they're
perfectly healthy diets you know I mean
think about the difference between
Mediterranean and Asian diets for
example they're really different and yet
people can thrive on it the same thing
is true of cats and dogs you can feed
them a lot of different kinds of foods
and they'll do just fine
what you need to make sure that they're
getting all their vitamins and minerals
and that the calcium and phosphate
balance is appropriate for bones but
beyond that you want to feed pets a
varied diet in the same way that you
want to feed yourself a very diet and if
you're eating a healthy diet a really
healthy diet you can feed your pet what
you're eating
if you think about it for a minute
that's how those animals were eating
well cats I guess were out hunting but
dogs the way that dogs got no tamed and
they descended from wolves over
thousands and thousands of years but
everybody thinks that the way that
happened was that they started hanging
around garbage dumps you know and if
you've had a dog you one of those dogs
that isn't finicky you know dogs will
eat anything
no I mean they were carnivores
originally they descended from
carnivorous wolves so they do just fine
with me you don't want to give him bones
unless you're watching them very
carefully because the bones can shatter
and do bad things but you wanna be
careful about the bones